monsieur victorin lurel
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
j'associe à cette prise de parole ma
collègue catherine conconne qui n'a pu
se libérer pour être parmi nous je tiens
à remercier la condition et son
rapporteur d'avoir réintroduit certains
articles 2 6 curieusement supprimée à
l'assemblée je le voudrais en cohérence
et en responsabilité je le voterai
moyenne aux seconds à l'adoption des
amendements déposés par mon groupe et
notamment celui vers introduisant
l'ensemble des justificatifs nécessaires
à la délivrance du pass sanitaires ou du
pass aux frontières il n'est pas
raisonnable à mes yeux de ne retenir que
le test négatif comme ces âmes au risque
de déligitimer la vaccination je le
voudrais
car je restitue le début de cette crise
sanitaire quand ira à fins de protéger
nos compatriotes
je rappelle que de les 26 mars 2020 je
publiais un communiqué par lequel je
demandais à ce que toutes les
initiatives soient prises ou faire de la
guadeloupe mais s'est livré pour la
martinique et la guyane un isolat
sanitaires
j'aurais intérêt cette proposition dans
un courrier au premier ministre le 5
avril 2020 afin de limiter
l'introduction la propagation du virus
sur l'archipel je dois vous dire mon
étonnement d'entendre ceux là mêmes
qu'il y a deux ans exigent une
protection absolue de nos frontières par
directrice de déplacement usées
aujourd'hui d'un mot fort et
grandiloquent résultat outre mer tels
que discriminations exclusion
stigmatisation pour qualifier cette
possibilité de mise en place le pass
sanitaire de passes frontières ou de
certificats de voyage à l'heure au moins
de la moitié des guadeloupéens et des
martiniquais et les guyanais
vacciner je considère qu'il est de bonne
politique lesage politiquement de
salubrité publique de permettre aux
pouvoirs publics d'empêcher la survenue
d'une vague qui ne manquera pas d'être
meurtrière qu'elle législateur serions
nous si nous refusions de donner la
faculté de protéger une population
indéniablement vulnérables
potentiellement confrontés à un virus ou
mental et je finis
espérons répétons le la mise en place de
ce pass se fera de manière proportionnée
au risque de menaces graves au cas par
cas et après consultation des
collectivités parlementaires concernés
c'est le centre des amendements déposés
par le grand bien
monsieur patients
sur le président celui né se cherche les
la lutte contre l'épidémie de kovy 19 a
poussé les précédents gouvernements à
prendre ces deux dernières années des
mesures de restriction des libertés
des mesures difficilement acceptables et
acceptées qui n'ont pas toujours été
comprise déçu jusqu'à ce jour notamment
dans les outre mer
aujourd'hui nous avons une vision plus
claire de l'épidémie et de ses
conséquences nous savons mieux traiter
la maladie c'est pourquoi nous ne
pouvons plus nous permettre de surréagir
en cela la nouvelle rédaction de
l'article 2 que nous propose le
rapporteur est à mon sens équilibrée et
elle préserve la possibilité de demander
aux voyageurs entrant ou territoire
national pas sanitaires pour ralentir
l'import de nouveaux variants ce même
pas ce point est demandée pour aller
dans un des territoires d'outre-mer sous
certaines conditions et ce dans ce seul
sens
l'objectif affiché ici est clairement de
protéger les outre-mer sans les isoler
c'est là toute la différence par rapport
aux situations antérieures
l'application de ce pass ne se fera
qu'en cas de risque de saturation du
système de santé de la collectivité
concernée et qu'après consultation de
l'exécutif local et des parlementaires
du territoire
l'exécutif local pourra également faire
la demande de l'application de ce pass
sony dell enfin le bassin et ter ne
pourra être qu'un test de dépistage
urologique tiff il n'est pas question
ici de passes vaccinale il ne pourrait
plus être exigé la présentation d'un
certificat de vaccination comme c'est le
cas dans le droit en vigueur dans ces
conditions la possibilité pour le
gouvernement de rétablir entre les
déplacements me semble juste et
proportionnée
c'est pourquoi je voterais l'article 2
dans cette série d'accidents et j'espère
que nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale quand seront tout autant je
vous en remercie merci cher collègue
madame conway mouret
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je
souhaiterais prendre la parole
maintenant pour convaincre les collègues
de cet hémicycle ce qui est peut être un
peu ambitieux du bien fondé des
amendements présentés par nos collègues
mélanie noël yann son crâne et et jean
yves le conte dans le cadre de cet
article 2 tous vont dans le sens du
respect du droit fondamental des
français de l'étranger accéder au
territoire national gouvernement dans un
souci de réduire la propagation du virus
a fait le choix du confinement en france
et la réduction de la mobilité des
personnes venant de l'étranger en
multipliant les obstacles voyage ne
pouvait peut-être pas en être autrement
puisque l'objectif était à la fois de
protéger la population et gérer un
service de santé sous tension est en
grande souffrance c'est en travaux
déplacement malheureusement eu de
nombreux dégâts collatéraux sur le plan
familial et personnel il est nécessaire
aujourd'hui d'éviter qu'ils ne se
répètent d'autant que cette entrave aux
déplacements et peut-être ralenti la
circulation du virus mais ne l'a pas
empêché alors que les vagues se
succèdent il semble nécessaire de tirer
les leçons de la gestion passée de cette
crise ne plus l'être la question de
bloquer la mobilité nos compatriotes qui
souhaitent rentrer chez eux mais nous
devons rester responsable ces français
sont aujourd'hui majoritairement
vacciner et sont en conformité avec ce
qui est requis dans leur pays de
résidence la france ne peut pas leur
interdire l'entrée du territoire alors
qu'ils n'ont parfois pas eu localement
accès aux vaccins reconnu par l' oms ou
par l'agencé européenne du médicament
démultiplier les justificatifs reconnu
permettre un test à la rive et impliquer
l'ensemble des élus locaux les conseils
des français de l'étranger devraient
faciliter cette mobilité tout en
respectant et on est en conformité avec
les règles en place les amendements
proposés le permettent alors que les
français établis hors de france semble
les grands oubliés de ce texte
merci amendement 28 madame noël merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre sur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues j'ai déjà largement exposé les
motivations qui m'a amené à supprimer
l'article 2 je n'y reviendrai donc pas
je souhaitais juste rajouté parmi les
arguments qui m'amène à mettre un doute
sur cet article
c'est la question des départements
frontaliers c'est le cas pour la
haute-savoie doublement frontalier avec
la suisse et l'italie et je m'interroge
vrai véritablement sur les conséquences
d'un tel dispositif sur les échanges
transfrontaliers
quotidien extrêmement nombreux qui
caractérise nos territoires comment
seront ils traités sur merci merci
monsieur le rapporteur avis de la
commission sur le 28
bien entendu de la commission n'est pas
favorable aux 28 elle a fait vraiment un
traitement très proportionnée dans des
situations très improbable la commission
pense qu'il faut autoriser le
gouvernement à prendre des dispositions
tout à fait exceptionnelle pour que dans
une situation vraiment d'urgence on
protège nos frontières contre l'arrivée
de voyageurs en provenance d'un pays où
viendraient d'apparaître invariants très
dangereux du coc vide c'est simple
s'agissant de notre outre-mer nous
savons à quel point son système
hospitalier est fragile et s'il doit y
avoir une flambée de l'épidémie outre
mer il vaut mieux que
permettions aussi au gouvernement de
faire en sorte que on limite l'accès à
l'outre-mer à des voyageurs dont la
probabilité qu'il soit porteur du virus
est faible et a été attestée nous avons
voulu que tout ceci repose sur la
présentation d'un test ça n'est pas
parce que nous considérons que la
vaccination ne doit pas continuer à être
mises en oeuvre tout au contraire la
vaccination doit continuer à être mises
en oeuvre mais vous avez observé qu'avec
le variant au micron la vaccination
ne protège des contaminations que dans
une minorité de cas et par conséquent
vous pouvez avoir une personne vaccinée
qui montent à bord d'un avion dans un
pays où apparaît un variant très
dangereux du coc vide et qui en réalité
sera porteur du virus et contaminant et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
prévu que pour protéger nos frontières
de l'apparition d'un nouveau virus il
vaut mieux même si c'est plus
contraignant pour le voyageur il est
vrai que ils produisent un test négatif
et dans ce cas là mais c'est un cas que
personne ne pense que ce cas est
probable mais nous devons être prudents
si jamais ce cas se réaliser quand même
d'un variant extrêmement dangereux alors
il faut à réagir très vite et je vous
rappelle que la seule alternative
si nous ne votons pas l'article 2 elle
existe d'ailleurs elle est très simple
interdiction des vols en provenance de
ce pays d'une part ou d'autre part mis
en quarantaine de tous les voyageurs des
avions en provenance de ce pays vous
réquisitionné à
centre de tourisme social vous y mettez
pendant une dizaine de jours tous les
voyageurs pensez bien que nos
compatriotes qui reviennent de
l'étranger seraient contents qu'on ne
laisse que ces solutions au gouvernement
dans un cas vraiment tout à fait
exceptionnelle et improbable où il
faudrait se protéger quant l'émergence
contre l'émergence d'un virus très
dangereux c'est vrai je fais appel
raison je crois que ce dispositif est
vraiment très marginal très exceptionnel
mais si les événements qu'il permet de
traiter se produise on préfèrera
utiliser ce dispositif de tri ciblées à
l'entrée dans l'avion dans le pays de
provenance un dispositif d'interdiction
du vol de ses avions vers la france où
un dispositif de quarantaine ça me
paraît tellement simple vraiment je vous
demande d'y réfléchir pour tous ceux qui
hésitent encore l'espace d'un instant
nous sommes là pour le service de notre
pays pour le service des français et
nous devons accepter me semble-t-il de
maintenir des précautions qui sont
extrêmement utiles même si ça peut être
déplaisant de devoir produire le
résultat d'un test parce que personne
n'apprécie devoir introduire un
écouvillon dans ses narines
bien monsieur le ministre avait du
gouvernement
c'est le président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs madame
la sénatrice
votre amendement a pour objet de
supprimer la possibilité d'exiger la
présentation de passer des circonstances
l'imposent cependant l'émergence
régulière de nouveaux variants de
lakovic 19 à l'étranger ainsi que
l'évolution actuelle de la situation
sanitaire nécessite d'habilité le
gouvernement à prendre ses mesures de
freinage si nécessaire le conseil
scientifique a estimé que la
prolongation d'un pass frontières ou le
pass variant pour être plus fidèle aux
débats de votre commission des lois et
proportionnées aux évolutions possibles
de l'épidémie et qu'il s'agit d'un
élément de la stratégie commune à bâtir
avec nos partenaires européens cette
faculté expirera en janvier 23 enfin si
elle diminue progressivement avec le
temps et nécessite un rappel la
vaccination confère bien une immunité
efficace permettant de réduire la
transmissibilité du virus est le risque
contracté une forme grave parlé
également de la problèmes étaient des
frontières que vous le savez peut-être
j'habite en moselle au pays des trois
frontières et l'ensemble des mesures
prises n'ont pas posé de problème
particulier pour l'instant pour les
frontaliers pour ces raisons le goût
ernement est défavorable à cet
amendement
c'est madame noël
oui je dois vous dire qu'il n'ya pas
qu'en avion qu'on arrive vers des pays
étrangers il ya également aux voitures
c'est le cas de la haute savoie l'ain on
a cent mille travailleurs frontaliers
qui franchissent chaque jour la
frontière qu'en sera-t-il pour ces zones
frontalières
bien aller je mets au voile amendement
28 avec deux avis négatifs qui est pour
jeudi qui est pour
d'accord qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est rejeté
je suis saisi de deux amendements
discussion commune monsieur richard
peut-être le 68 et le 66 oui monsieur le
président je pense qu'on pourrait sous
votre contrôle soumettre un seul de ces
amendements aux voix parce que quand
j'ai déposé monsieur malrieu compte
qu'ils étaient en vérité complémentaires
et donc le sujet est le suivant c'est
que lorsque le gouvernement prendra par
décret s'il est amené à le faire la
décision d'imposer la vérification donc
du certificat de santé pour accéder à un
territoire d'outre-mer ou un territoire
étranger on lui demande de le faire
après avis de la haute autorité de santé
or à la réflexion et en tenant compte
des avis des personnes
les mieux informés de du milieu il a
semblé que ce n'était pas la haute
autorité de santé qui était la plus
préparés à donner cet avis en plus il
faut qu'elle le donne en toute urgence
puisque ça peut être des déclenchements
quelques heures mais qu' il valait mieux
en référé à la l'organisme qui va
remplacer le conseil scientifique qui
certes ne figure pas lui-même dans la
loi puisqu'il est prévu qu'il soit créé
par décret et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'article l'amendement pardon
66 prévoit que la décision du ministre
d'instaurer cette ce mécanisme de
vérification de
de contrôle de certificats de voyages
soit des filets après avis de l'autorité
scientifique établie par décret qui est
là le successeur du conseil scientifique
richard si je comprends bien vous vous
avez défendu en fait le 66 vous retire
le choc lui retirer le 68 parce qu'il
cherche la beauté pour le 66 très bien
donc avis de la commission et du
gouvernement que sur le 66 favorable
favorable avait du gouvernement
avis favorable également des surprises
qu'est ce qu'il ya
sur ces amendements vous êtes combien
c'est un vrai débat monsieur le comte
d'abord
après même sur des sommes
que le président ce qui est important
c'est qu'on ait besoin d'un avis
scientifiques éclairé
obligatoire avant la publication de ce
type de décret dans la mesure où ce type
de décret va clarifier le type de test
les le type de schéma vaccinal qui sera
autorisée ou les conditions dans
lesquelles 1 et tout laisse qui sera
demandé en particulier en ce qui
concerne les schémas vaccinaux
jusqu'à présent les choses étaient dans
le décret sans que la loi ne prévoit qui
est une autorité médicale qui le valide
et c'était quand même problématique
parce que lorsque les personnes étaient
vaccinées dans un pays étranger et qu'on
leur disait ben faut refaire des vaccins
pour avoir leur schéma vaccinal complet
il se retrouvait avec 5 vaccin parfois
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
important d'avoir une un avis médical
dans tous les cas dès lors qu'on a on
demande on demande ce type de
certificats donc je laisserais je crois
que dans tous les cas passés par une
telle autorité scientifique avant que le
gouvernement puisse émettre un décret
est indispensable parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous avions des situations qui était
risqué parce que l'ensemble des schémas
vaccinaux n'était pas validée par une
autorité de santé lorsqu'on avait
commencé à être quand on avait été
vacciné dans un autre pays ou lorsque la
troisième dose n'était pas arn et
n'était pas reconnue et qu'il fallait se
faire vacciner une fois plus
merci monsieur daumier
merci monsieur le président donc à
l'occasion de cet amendement de notre
collègue alain richard que nous allons
approuver on voit surgir l'autorité
scientifique eux voilà qui va être créée
par voie réglementaire et qu'il a
succédé au conseil scientifique mais je
trouve qu'ils seraient de bons de bon
aloi que le gouvernement nous apporte
tout de même un certain nombre
d'informations sur la création de cette
autorité scientifique indépendante parce
que ça n'est pas rien d'ailleurs le
conseil scientifique avait été créée par
la loi enfin par une décision du chef de
l'état va guider ensuite par le mode par
l'omc par le parlement pardon or quand
nous avons rédigé le rapport de la
commission denquête avec catherine de
roche et sylvie vermeillet nous avons
traité cette question et en faisant des
propositions notamment sur le champ de
compétence de cette autorité sur la la
la la composition de cette autorité sur
le fait qu'on devait se doter dans notre
pays d'un outil de veille d' alerte qui
dépassent probablement le champ
strictement sanitaire parce que d'autres
crises peuvent survenir et on pense tous
au lien avec la crise climatique actuel
qui nécessitent des réponses importantes
des mesures de premier ordre et un des
défauts
cavenne au dispositif
c'est l'absence de reconnaissance par
l'opinion publique
beaucoup des problèmes auxquels nous
avons fait face c'est que la légitimité
du conseil scientifique étaient mal
fondées et l'inde important donc de
créer une instance scientifique qui crée
sa légitimité non seulement vers le
parlement mais envers l'opinion publique
pourrait après reconnu par nos
compatriotes enfin en cas de crise et
qu'on évite des débats qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être voilà alors nous souscrivons
à l'amendement dan richards mais il
serait de bon ton que le gouvernement
nous en dise tout de même un peu plus
alors qu'on cite dans un texte de loi
qu'on va voter une instance qui n'existe
pas et dont on ne sait rien au jour
d'aujourd'hui très bien allez je me vois
donc le soir
la présidente de roche oui moi je n'ai
pas grand chose à ajouter à ce qu'a dit
bernard jomier
il devait y avoir au départ dans ce
texte un article 3 qui crée en effet un
un comité nouveau nous étions engagés si
c'était le cas ce que la commission des
affaires sociales s'en saisissent eu
égard aux conclusions de la commission
denquête que nous avions fait sur la
première partie de la crise sanitaire
bon à l'occasion de cet amendement n'est
fait on délègue à une autorité qui
n'existe pas encore puisque le décret
n'est pas prêt et dont on ne sait
absolument rien ce qui ce que va
représenter cette autorité bon donc moi
je souffrais néanmoins le rapporteur
parce que je suis plutôt d'un caractère
docile mais
plutôt mais néanmoins je trouve ça quand
même un petit peu un petit peu spécial
même si le conseil d'état dit qu'en
effet c'était par décret mais on crée
une autorité qui quand même n'est pas
négligeable quand on pense à ascq et
celle alors qu'il existe déjà des tas de
l'autorité en matière de santé j'aurais
aimé voir un peu plus d'explications
merci madame la présidente et je ne peux
pardon
jeu non et je ne peux que partager vos
interrogations avant de mettre aux voix
le 66 avec le
oui monsieur richard
au monsieur le président je veux abondé
dans le sens de bernard jomier je crois
qu'il y bien que de temps en temps quand
même le parlement se rappelle qu'il ya
une distinction entre législatif et
réglementaire que en effet la création
d'une instance consultative madame la
présidente ait pas de l'autorité et du
domaine réglementaire mais vu
l'importance du sujet je me permets de
ceux de suggérer au ministre à un moment
de notre débat où il aura pu se préparer
un peu à nous donner les fils de ce que
sera le décret qui instaurera la
nouvelle autorité scientifique
très bien bien et bien dans ces
conditions d'une régularité absolue
monsieur le ministre
eh bien je pense que si vous pouvez
lever les inquiétudes ce sera parfait
avant le vote
oui monsieur le président il sera
porteur mesdames et messieurs j'ai les
sénateurs quelques éléments en tout cas
cette autorité sera une autorité
scientifique
indépendante qui émettra des avis qui
pourra s'autosaisir les avis seront
public et transmis bien sûr l'assemblée
et au sénat
bien allez on va pas lancer un débat
là-dessus aujourd'hui je mets aux voix
l'amendement 66 qui a donc deux avis
favorables qui est pour
allez allez allez on se ressaisit
kippour voilà merci qui est contre et
contre
vous êtes contre annonce vous gardiez la
main levée qui s'abstient
très bien cet amendement est donc adopté
peut essayer de faire il ya quatre
amendements identiques si chacun y met
un peu du sien on peut les faits avant
le lever l'amendement cette notion
benarroch oui monsieur le président le
présent amendement vise à exclure les
mineurs de moins de 18 ans du certificat
sanitaire de voyage
qui les contraindrait à la présentation
de test de dépistage
la défenseur des droits claire et doit
rappeler à de nombreuses reprises que la
restriction d'activité liberté d'aller
et de venir sont particulièrement
préjudiciables pour les mineurs cela
peut affecter durablement leur
développement et leur état psychique des
restrictions de liberté ne peuvent
s'apprécier qu'au considération de l'âge
des personnes auxquelles la loi
s'applique alors que le gouvernement a
choisi d'enlever les obligations de
masques dans les lieux clos qu'il en
appelle à la responsabilité de chacun
pour se protéger et protéger les autres
de la pandémie qui continue il nous
paraît disproportionnée et absolument
pas prioritaire de faire peser ses
obligations sur des mineurs
ou coupons
madame noël le 30 merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues il
s'agit d'un amendement de repli qui
souhaite tempérer le dispositif en
excluant de fait l'ensemble des mineurs
comme nos collègues députés avaient eu
la sagesse de le faire en matière de
politique de santé orienté à destination
des mineurs les experts valorise l'étude
et la recherche d'un équilibre entre les
bénéfices et les risques si bien des
adolescents français sont déjà vaccinés
ou on est déjà eu le colis de 19 82% ont
un schéma vaccinal complet la question
de la limitation de l'accès est posée
pour les familles en provenance de pays
où l'accès au vaccin ou au dispositif au
dispositif de dépistage n'est pas
optimale dans une logique générale la
politique de lutte contre la crise du
coville devrait continuer de se
concentrer sur les populations cibles
celle qui risque d'être impacté
durablement et durement par cette
maladie sans merci merci madame mais
leur bonne oui monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur ministre
dans le même sens que mes deux collègues
à l'assemblée nationale on avait bien
réussi à remonter donc l'aja l'âge de la
maturité lui majorité à 18 ans et là il
s'agit aussi de te demander à ce que les
enfants ne subissent pas les tests aux
frontières vous imaginez bien une
famille et si l'enfant est positif le
sol de la famille la culpabilité et
qu'il va ressentir les difficultés
psychologiques sont déjà fort taux la
jeunesse ça payé un lourd tribut depuis
deux ans et il est là de notre
bienveillance pour les moins de 18 ans
merci merci
le 62 2 oui
merci monsieur le président donc ça a
été dit par plusieurs de nos collègues
il s'agit donc avec cet amendement
d'exclure les mineurs de l'usaj du
nouveau certificat sanitaire de voyage
comme l'a souligné la défenseure des
droits ces restrictions droit d'aller et
de venir pour ces jeunes personnes sont
particulièrement préjudiciables pour
leur état de santé psychique notamment
comme ça cela a été rappelé par notre
collègue benarroch et nous appuyons ses
propos les restrictions de liberté
notamment
pour les plus jeunes s'avèrent souvent
catastrophiques nous demandons donc pour
les moins de 16 ans que nous et nous
savons que ceux ci les moins de 16 ans
sont tributaires de la décision de leurs
parents qui les font vacciner ou pas
ainsi comment porter préjudice à des
enfants ou à des jeunes qui n'auraient
eu leur mot à dire concernant leur
vaccination enfin il s'agirait peut-être
désormais de veiller davantage nous
pensons au bien-être de notre jeunesse
qui a déjà beaucoup souffert de cette
pandémie notamment et ça a été dit dans
leur mal être psychique de deux années
de mesures qui ont été restrictives et
qui sont allés jusqu au confinement à
plusieurs reprises et à l'arrêt de toute
activité
parfois scolaire et de loisirs nous
pensons plus glam plus que jamais qu'il
faut prendre soin de nos jeunes d'autant
qu'ils ont besoin de voyager qu'ils ont
besoin de profiter certains ont pendant
le temps scolaire mais aussi pendant les
vacances pour l'apprentissage d'une
langue et donc ne les privons pas et ne
priverons pas notre jeunesse de pouvoir
voyager pendant cette période merci
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
je voudrais monsieur le président
rappelait que nous avons à bruges est
définitivement toutes les dispositions
sur le pass vaccinale passe sanitaires
premièrement donc il ne s'agit pas de
restreindre en quoi que ce soit les
libertés de la jeunesse mais nous avons
dit aussi et vous avez repoussé des
amendements de suppression de l'article
2 que dans des cas hautement improbable
totalement exceptionnel d'apparition
dans un pays donné d'invariants
tuco vide
extrêmement nocif il s'agirait de
protéger aux frontières de la france
l'accès à notre territoire pour des
repères pour des personnes
potentiellement porteuses de ce variant
et quand amy nantes alors soit on pense
que cette disposition est utile et à ce
moment là on ne fait pas d'exception
pour les 12 18 ans soit on pense que
cette disposition est inutile et on vote
comme certaines ne collègues l'ont fait
l'amendement de suppression mais on ne
peut pas à la fois dire que dans cette
situation improbable hautement
exceptionnel mais très dangereux il faut
se protéger et dire que les jeunes de 12
à 18 ans ne devrait pas être pris en
compte parce que sinon les jeunes de 10
12 à 18 ans peuvent être porteurs du
virus et l'introduire sur le territoire
national accélérer l'entrée de ce virus
sur le territoire national donc si votre
préoccupation est dans ce cas de figure
si particulier de protéger nos
frontières il faut que les 12 18 ans
soit compris dans la mesure et ça n'est
pas être contre la jeunesse ou contre
aucune catégorie d'âge que de le dire je
crois tout simplement qu'il faut que
nous soyons cohérents après le refus que
vous avez manifesté de supprimer cet
article 2 et donc l'avis est défavorable
sur ces amendements
avis du ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs aux
amendements visent à exempter les
individus mineurs du champ d'application
des passants revenant sur le texte
adopté par votre commission des lois
permettant d'instituer si nécessaire un
pass pour les personnes âgées d'au moins
12 ans or s'il développe moins de formes
graves laissait largement démontrées il
est désormais acquis quand même que tout
autant que leurs aînés les jeunes
citoyens sont des vecteurs de
propagation du virus
ils peuvent tout à fait être porteur
d'un nouveau variant le taux d'incidence
des 10 19 ans a été récemment en forte
hausse
de 144 cas pour 100000 habitants durant
la semaine du 30 mai il a atteint 759
cas au cours de la semaine du 4 juillet
les mineurs de plus de 12 ans peuvent
réaliser un examen de dépistage
virologique sans difficulté je rappelle
qu'il est gratuit pour eux par ailleurs
si votre chambre rétabli le certificat
de rétablissement et le justificatif de
statut vaccinal je souhaite vous
préciser que la vaccination est ouverte
aux mineurs depuis le 15 juin 2021 et
que l'union européenne a autorisé pour
ce public deux vaccins l'un développé
par pfizer biotech l'autre par modern a
en outre les mineurs âgés de 16 ans
peuvent être vaccinés à leur seule
demande et ceux de 12 à 16 ans avec
l'accord d'un seul parent de plus les
mineurs ont accès comme tout à chacun au
certificat de rétablissement pendant
plusieurs mois suivant la réalisation
d'un test positif
la possibilité d'exiger un pass à partir
de 12 ans est enfin ce nanar
international et européen
pour ces raisons j'émets un avis
défavorable à vos amendements
merci monsieur lui soit deux amendements
identiques dans l'objet d'une discussion
commune le 55 présentée par monsieur
bonnecarrère
vous avez tous écouté la présentant vous
avez tous écouté la présentation de
notre à porter l'article 2 est divisé en
deux parties une partie une qui concerne
les transports internationaux une partie
2 qui concerne les transports entre la
corse les outre mer et la métropole la
partie une les transports internationaux
et dans l'esprit de notre rapporteur
traité sur la base de l'apparition de
varia le gouvernement pourrait en cas
d'apparition dans variant quelque part
dans le monde pour reprendre des
dispositions dites de filtrage pour
reprendre la formulation qui a été
utilisée tout à l'heure pour la relation
avec l'outre-mer et la corse la logique
est différente et elle s'appuie
exclusivement sur l'idée de ne pas créer
de situations sur charge hospitalière
outre mer cette seconde logique a
conduit notre rapporteur a une vraie
d'action dans lequel il prévoit que
seuls
les trajets entre la métropole et outre
mer ou la corse pourrait faire l'objet
de mesures préventives de la part du
gouvernement c'est rationnel puisque
c'est la logique à partir de laquelle il
a construite sa rédaction le seul
problème que nous n'avons pas vu
immédiatement
c'est que chacun sait vous avez par
exemple les mouvements de population
réguliers entre le brésil et la guyane
vous pouvez en avoir entre les hauts
plateaux africa et et mayotte entre
autres exemples si demain vous avez un
virus qui invariants qui apparaît au
brésil vous pourrez assurer une
filtration entre recife où rio de
janeiro et paris mais vous ne pourrez
pas le faire entre la guyane et paris
donc la rédaction cet amendement vise à
permettre de corriger ce trou dans le
filet pour reprendre une formulation qui
a été utilisée également dans la
situation du trajet dans le sens retour
j'ajoute que la commission des lois a eu
un regard favorable sur cet amendement
qui dont la rédaction est alignée sur
celle de mes collègues qui vont
intervenir le rédaction ils ont été plus
complète merci merci l'amendement 65
donc identiques présentés par monsieur
mohamed failli
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues les
motifs de notre amendement viennent
d'être exprimée avec l' art et par notre
collègue philippe bonnecarrère je veux
rappeler que cet amendement est en
cohérence avec l'article approuvé en
commission un amendement de protection
du territoire contre les variants qui
sont susceptibles de circuler à
l'étranger dans des pays limitrophes
faut-il rappeler le cheminement des
variants bêta et delta lesquels ont eu
un rôle actif dans de précédentes vagues
je veux bien insister ici sur les points
suivants tout d'abord au terme de cet
amendement les conditions et critères
d'application du certificat au
déplacement depuis les outre-mer sont
resserrés par rapport au droit en
vigueur ensuite l'amendement conserve
plus modifications intervenues lors des
débats à l'assemblée nationale puis lors
de l'examen en commission au sénat
s'agissant de l'application du
certificat pour les déplacements à
destination des outre-mer notre
amendement prévoit d'ailleurs lui-même
la consultation des exécutifs locaux et
des parlementaires des collectivités
d'outre-mer concernés en amont d'une
application du certificat pour les
déplacements depuis les outre mer enfin
c'est de ces dispositions consiste
seulement dans une faculté que le
gouvernement ne pouvait mettre en oeuvre
que jusqu'au 31 janvier 2023 au plus
tard dans l'intérêt de la santé publique
et aux seules fins de lutter contre la
propagation de l'épidémie de covile 19
de manière strictement proportionnées
aux risques sanitaires encourus et
appropriée aux circonstances de temps et
de lieu et qu'il devra cesser
d'appliquer sans délai lorsqu'elle n'est
plus nécessaire je cite ici la loi je
remercie ainsi l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis est favorable
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur
ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
le caractère insulaire de la plupart des
outre-mer est la proximité de pays
étrangers connaissent en situation
sanitaire très diverses qui ont
effectivement donné lieu à l'apparition
de nouveaux variants brésil afrique du
sud nécessite de permettre l'application
de la mesure aux voyageurs en provenance
d outre mer à destination de l'hexagone
pour éviter une plus forte diffusion du
virus le caractère très touristique de
ces tours histoire et les brassages
particuliers auxquels ils sont exposés
sont également à prendre en compte à cet
égard en outre la symétrie que vous
souhaitez instauré entre l'hexagone et
d'outre-mer existe dans notre droit
depuis l'introduction du pass-foncier
air sans que cela ait soulevé de
difficultés particulières auparavant
votre amendement d'indiens maintient à 6
déséquilibres existants et on sait que
la mesure est utile vers l'hexagone
comme entre territoires ultramarins pour
limiter la diffusion de nouveaux
variants apparu à l'étranger qui
entrerait sur le territoire par les
outre mer dans tous les cas je rappelle
que vous ne votez pas qu une
habilitation instauré le pass variant
lors des déplacements depuis les
outre-mer à destination de l'hexagone et
ne sera mis en oeuvre par la première
ministre que si nécessaire enfin
l'amendement prévoit la consultation des
exécutifs et parlementaires concernées
avant toute application du dispositif
garantissant une décision concertée avec
les populations ultramarines ce que je
ne peux qu'approuver pour ces raisons
avis favorable
merci
alors oui monsieur anoh
merci madame la présidente je vais je
m'exprime parce que autant autant le
texte de la commission modifié proposé
par le rapporteur m'allait très bien sur
la protection de nos territoires
notamment en cas de saturation du
système hospitalier autant le message
qu'on envoie aujourd'hui aux français
d'outre-mer c'est qu'on vous partez de
la bretagne pour la paris on peut vous
demander impasse c'est exactement le
même message tout venait d'envoyer ces
cons vous venez d'un territoire
ultramarin de saint clar micron pour
aller vers l'hexagone on peut exiger à
un moment donné la preuve que vous ne
soyez pas atteint de kovy d' allah vous
me direz c'est une possibilité monsieur
le ministre je vous ai entendu
effectivement moi je parle du symbole et
du message qu'on envoie aux territoires
si certains ici n'ont pas encore compris
que le résultat des élections qu'on a
connu cette année avait été impacté et
orthez complètement par la manière dont
la crise sanitaire avait été gérée sur
certaines mesures qui n'ont pas été
prises écoutez par les exécutifs locaux
et merci monsieur le rapporteur d'avoir
intégré les exécutifs au niveau de la
vie donnée par le représentant de l'état
sur les mesures envisagées je pense
qu'on n'a pas encore compris le message
qui est envoyé à nos ultras marins et
c'est vrai que le vrai message intégrés
dans le texte de la commission c'est une
protection parce que le vrai sujet pour
nous c'est la pénétration du virus sur
notre territoire
pour éviter le risque de saturation et
c'est pas l'un vers ce même si
effectivement monsieur missa du brassage
chacun dans nos bassins géographiques
c'est pas vraiment là le sujet
d'ailleurs il suffit d'observer le
décalage dans le temps de la crise
sanitaire en outre-mer par rapport à
l'hexagone je pense que c'est simplement
faire preuve de pragmatisme et moi
sincèrement et je les dis à mes
collègues je m'opposerai à ces deux
amendements qui sont de mon point de vue
un mauvais message envoyé aux outre mer
on voyait à tous les français parce que
quand vous partez d'un vol direct
ultramarins vers l'hexagone on peut vous
demander une preuve de la même manière
que celle qu'on peut exiger à l'entrée
sur le territoire français mais on est
en france mais peut-être qu'il faut
encore le rappeler visiblement et ça
n'est semble-t-il pas tout à fait
claires sur merci merci monsieur lurel
madame la présidente je vais me michel
collègues je partage totalement l'avis
de mon collègue est ardemment mais
totalement parce que le message est
envoyé là c'est de dire que si deux mais
il devait y avoir une circulation encore
plus intensive du virus il peut être
importé des autres mais on est en train
de le créer là une sorte de frontière
virtuelle que je ne comprends pas et je
peux entendre voir comprendre le sens de
l'amendement mais je veux pas
l'approuver de dire que en fait pour
résumer ça il y à symétrie ce que l'on
demande au départ de la métropole eh
bien on va l'exigé aussi au départ de
aujourd'hui vous chante ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui vous êtes en train de
changer un système qui fonctionne le
mieux pratiquement deux ans je ne
comprends pas accueilli le motive même
le rapporte qu' pantin fin et subtil
juriste n'a pas osé demander ça et c'est
vous qui demandez ça en ostracisant
davantage beaucoup j'aime pas mais que
je vais utiliser les autres mais je vais
voter contre ces deux amendements
merci oui monsieur patient
puisque mes collègues après les mots je
voulais moi aussi proféré donc tout
simplement pour dire que je voudrais
passer deux amendements
oui madame la présidente
mes chers collègues tout ce qui est
excessif est vain
je viens d'entendre parler de strass
isation je viens d'entendre parler d'un
message qui ne serait pas passé
souvenez-vous lorsque cette pandémie a
commencé nous étions les premiers à
notre mère a demandé la protection de
nos territoires a demandé de la
solidarité
cet amendement c'est de la solidarité
parce que nous ne pouvons pas nous
contenter de demander de la solidarité
et qu'il y ait des mesures de protection
et de contrôle au départ de la métropole
et à partir de nos territoires nous en
laver les mains alors que nous savons
que des variants comme le 501 qui est né
en afrique du sud
vien a fini par gagner le monde entier
l'afrique du sud c'est un territoire qui
se trouve pas loin de mayotte pour venir
pour partir de l'afrique du sud à
mayotte il y à un moyen très simple
on va aux comores
et puis des comores à mayotte vous savez
c'est une passoire nous passons notre
temps à le dire ici de la même manière
du brésil fo en guyane est ce qu'il
faudrait taire cette situation juste
parce qu'on n'est pas en train de parler
d'immigration clandestine et bien moi je
suis désolé c'est une solidarité que je
dois à mes collègues de l'hexagone
n'importe qui à n'importe quel moment
peut passer de l'afrique du sud à
mayotte du jour au lendemain et c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que le variant 500
et a commencé à inquiéter parce que
connue en afrique du sud eh bien on la
détecte et aux comores donc moi c'est la
raison d'être de 7,1 mais seulement 17
amendements je pourrais dire on est
protégé en partant de l'hexagone on est
tranquille mais je pense que le variant
feu partir aussi de nos territoires vers
l'examen merci chers collègues même
jasmin
si le vent je voudrais dire tout
simplement qu'il faudrait qu'on soit un
moment donné cohérent
tantôt on parle de continuité
territoriale
alors il faudrait qu'on sache ce qu'on
veut vraiment merci
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix
c'est deux amendements donc que 55 et 65
qui ont reçu un avis favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement
qui est pour
qui est contre
e
je compte
c'est contre
écoutez on va vous demander un assis
debout je suis désolé ça va vous faire
bouger vos endormir et moir
qui est pour
ça
ce
qui est contre
et
qui s'abstient
ils sont adoptés
l'article 2 a finalement été adopté
largement
236 voix pour 27 voix contre place à
d'autres débats animée hier soir ceux
sur la réintégration des soignants non
vaccinés en effet le sénat inscrit dans
le projet de loi que cette obligation de
vaccination pourrait être suspendu dès
lors qu'elle ne sera plus justifié au vu
de l'évolution de l'épidémie ou des
connaissances médicales et scientifiques
une porte de sortie alors que l'exécutif
attend en fin de semaine l'avis de la
haute autorité de santé
nous en passer à l'article de biche et
les demandes de prise de parole et la
premier le premier monsieur lâm perdre
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre
hier l'académie de médecine a donné son
avis sur la réintégration des soignants
non vaccinés avançant un risque de perte
de cohésion et de confiance entre
malades et soignants il me semble
inapproprié de parler de confiance alors
que des feux font rage dans plusieurs
régions de france que des femmes et des
hommes sont poignardé en pleine rue nous
continuons d'exclure des professionnels
investis pour la sécurité de leurs
concitoyens
alors que l'hôpital est à l'agonie
nous continuons deskur des soignants
alors que alors même que nous avons
autorisé des personnels malades mais
vacciner à exercer auprès des patients
il a été reconnu que le vaccin n'empêche
pas la contamination et la vague que
nous avons connus après la mise en place
du pass vaccinale le démontre
aujourd'hui ce projet de loi
lève le pass vaccinale sur le territoire
hexagonal et 7 enfin monsieur le
rapporteur un souffle de liberté mais
c'est surtout la fin d'un dispositif
injuste inéquitable et parfaitement
contreproductif
cet article 2 bis a pour objet de
rétablir un peu de cohérence en
permettant aux agents publics non
vaccinés de réintégrer leur emploi dans
des modalités qui ne constitue pas une
charge supplémentaire pour l'état il en
va de la santé et de la sécurité des
français il en va de la cohérence
scientifique
mes chers collègues pour protéger
l'hôpital nous avons un ferme et des
français aujourd'hui pour protéger les
français nous nous nous nous nous vous
demandons monsieur le ministre de
libérer nos soignants nos forces de
l'ordre nos pompiers 140 professionnels
et 5000 volontaires et nous en avons
besoin
merci la parole à monsieur victorin
lurel
collègues
ceux de bis
introduit un principe de réintégration
des personnels suspendu
j'aimerais pouvoir dire et or dire
devant vous ce soir que je crois à la
science à la médecine et au progrès
il est bon de le répéter je suis pour la
vaccination car elle sauve des vies
c'est mon seul souci il me plaît de vous
dire de vous redire que je ne suis pas
opposé à l'intégration des personnels
suspendu
comment refuser un agent hospitalier
suspendu d'être réintégré par exemple
les jardins d'un hôpital
je me vois mal aller dieu c'est pas
possible bienne mais
je reste que
proposait le reste opposée à la
réintégration des personnels suspendu
des soignants non vaccinés au chevet des
malades ou des personnes fragiles aux
vulnérables
j'affirme ici de manière comme dirait
césaire haute lucide est conséquente que
je reste opposée à cette réintégration
je reste opposée c'est une exigence
morale
celle de l'exemplarité et de l'éthique
attaché aux soins et je rappellerai et
je n'aurai pas le répéter dans la
présentation de la rue du mans si j'ai
encore quelques minutes
au niveau national il ya 500 un film qui
seraient suspendus pour deux cent
soixante trois mille infirmières
75 médecins et pharmaciens pour 85 1000e
médecin 200 pompiers sur 40000 vous avez
eu quatre avis puisque le ministre nous
dit je veux un avis éclairé pour
objectiver la situation elle est déjà
objective et puisque vous avez l'avis du
comité scientifique fermement opposés la
vie de l'académie de médecine la
fédération hospitalière de france le
conseil national ont dit et je finis
madame le président de la fédération
nationale des sapeurs pompiers
merci la parole est à monsieur georges
patient
la vaccination est encore plus
obligation vaccine pour les personnels
de santé ont été très mal accueillie en
guyane pour ne pas dire plus je crois
pouvoir dire qu'il en a été de même dans
d'autres territoires ultramarins
l'obligation vaccinale en des piles et
des jeunots de contestation a finalement
été appliqué avec les sanctions prévues
en cas de non vaccination
au dernier décompte en guyane il y avait
1 86 personnes suspendues pour nos
vaccination les taux de vaccination qui
sont toujours à des niveaux encore
satisfaisant entre 75 et 80 8%
aussi l'état des connaissances
progressant tout comme la prise en
charge des malades qui convient dès lors
deux rivales réévalué pertinence de
l'obligation vaccinale si l'on n'estime
coloriste n'existe plus ou du moins
qu'il est faible alors il faudra
suspendant la mesure
c'est ce que propose cet article
additionnel
mais c'est également ce que sans vouloir
faire le gouvernement puisqu'il a saisi
sur ce sujet la haute autorité de santé
la semaine dernière monsieur le ministre
en cas d'avis négatif de la haute
autorité de santé il faudra néanmoins
donner des perspectives assez
personnelle clip très humaniste imaginer
les aménagements de leurs activités nous
ne pouvons les laisser indéfiniment sans
travail pouvons-nous même de le
permettre à l'heure où nombre de nos
services d'urgence sont en souffrance au
moment où je vous parle je pense
notamment au centre hospitalier de
l'ouest guyanais qui ne fonctionne pas
la nuit faute de personnel suffisant je
vous en remercie
merci même s'ils viennent noël merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme vous
le savez je me bats depuis maintenant un
an quasiment en faveur de l'abrogation
de l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
et des pompiers et je suis heureuse que
ce sujet prennent enfin tout ça passe
dans le débat public enfin car cette
mesure en oeuvre depuis presque un an a
fortement déstabilisé notre système de
soins et de secours face à certains qui
tente de minimiser les chiffres évoquant
que les soignants suspendu ne
représenterait que 0 53 % de nos
effectifs de santé que les pompiers
suspendu ne représenterait que 2 % des
effectifs il combien une bonne fois pour
toutes de rétablir la vérité sur ces
chiffres
très fortement sous-estimés qui ne
prennent pas en compte tous les
soignants qui ont démissionné de la
fonction publique tous ceux qui ont
demandé une mise en disponibilité
tous les professionnels libéraux les
médecins généralistes les sages femmes
les kinés qui ne relèvent pas de la
fonction publique hospitalière et qui ne
sont donc pas suspendu ils sont
interdits d'exercice monsieur le
ministre donnez nous des chiffres de
vrais chiffres alors que notre hôpital
est à l'agonie alors que la france brûle
au sens propre comme au sens figuré
nounou pays le luxe aujourd'hui de nous
passer de milliers de soignants et de
pompiers qui ont juste voulu exercer
leur libre choix comme n'importe quel
français à l'égard d'un vaccin qui ne
protège ni de la contamination
ni de la transmission du virus il n'y a
plus rien de sanitaires ni de
scientifiques dans tout cela nous sommes
face nous sommes face à une obstination
aveugle dogmatique et idéologique qui
nous conduit dans le mur monsieur le
rapporteur dans ces conditions permettez
moi de juger même si je me réjouis de
votre amendement que votre amendement
traitant de ce sujet est beaucoup trop
timide vous laisser une nouvelle fois la
main au gouvernement pour procéder à
cette réintégration lorsque les
conditions seront réunies pardon mais
c'est à nous députés sénateurs de le
faire et de le décider maintenant cette
obligation vaccinale elle a été mise en
oeuvre par la loi ce qu'une loi peut
faire une loi peut le défaire il ne faut
pas perdre une minute la situation est
trop grave et ce sera donc le sens d'un
de mes amendements merci monsieur le
questeur jean pierre sueur
oui devant eux cette nouvelle
intervention de notre collègue je dois
remercier marie noëlle lienemann qui
tout à l'heure à 10 avec tellement de
force ce que les vaccins importés à la
science la médecine et à la vie tout
simplement de dizaines et centaines de
millions de personnes je crois que c'est
très important de le redire je voulais
intervenir simplement sur une question
qui paraîtra formelle mais je me
souviens du jour funeste où la
conférence des présidents du sénat a
décidé que tous les rapporteurs serait
désormais tenues dans l'exercice de
leurs missions de déclarer devant la
commission un périmètre au sein duquel
on aurait le droit de déposer des
amendements et à l'extérieur duquel les
amendements seraient bannis j'ai
toujours été contre cette procédure qui
est attentatoire aux droits du parlement
ce qui me paraît d'ailleurs posé un
problème constitutionnel
eu égard au droit d'amendement mais je
sais qu'il existe l'article 45 et sans
doute at-on voulu prévenir
les décisions éventuelles du conseil
constitutionnel qui est très rare et
très rude sur cette question et alors je
me suis étonnée je m'étonne aussi en
sciences public que cet article de
l'huissier le fruit d'un amendement
soit apparue alors que le texte tel
qu'il nous a été présentée ne permet pas
de traiter de cette question c'est autre
chose alors naturellement j'ai entendu
la réponse de monsieur le rapporteur je
sais qu'il est là rappelle rappellera
ici je le suppose mais je vous assure
que cet épisode montre tout simplement
le caractère très arbitraire dans lequel
on peut tomber avec ce type de procédure
merci monsieur marc laménie
merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois sur
le reporter chars collègues tous les
articles sont importants brrr cet
article simplement je souhaitais
intervenir modestement concernant cet
article 2 bis qui fait référence à la
loi du 5 août 2021 en n'oubliant pas de
rappeler bas tout le travail qu'a fait
la commission des lois depuis mars e2020
dès le 1er confinement il ya eu aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de sujets
particulièrement sensibles dramatique et
cette loi qui fait référence à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire loi du 5
août 2021 certes il ya des amendements
et je crois que tous les amendements
sont toujours
à la fois intéressant et qui suscite
aussi des débats des réactions et je
crois que méritent aussi du respect
il ya certes des amendements concernant
cet article 2 bis de suppression il ya
aussi et surtout des amendements qui
visent ou de à réintégrer les agents ou
fonction publique ou autres bien entendu
les personnels soignants suspendu en
effet des milliers de soignants les
sapeurs-pompiers forces de sécurité qui
sont
concernés et qui ont été aussi depuis
plus de deux ans particulièrement très
sollicité beaucoup de collègues ont
rappelé aussi les besoins en personnel
au niveau des hôpitaux de la fonction
publique hospitalière tous les
établissements de soins de santé et
c'est vrai que les sapeurs-pompiers qui
sont aussi et toutes les forces de
sécurité très très sollicités encore
plus en ce moment on est mérite aussi
bien entendu notre respect notre
reconnaissance
sujet hautement sensible mais d'un souci
j'irai de essayer de trouver le bon sens
et c'est vraiment très très compliqué
donc je j'écouterai avec attention les
avis du rapporteur de la commission des
lois pour me pour le vote concernant cet
article 2 bis merci beaucoup merci même
cécile cukierman oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues tout d'abord et je veux
peut-être le rappeler en préalable je
fais partie de ceux nombreux ici qui ont
toujours été convaincus que le vaccin à
défaut de solder cette pandémie était en
tout cas une arme efficace pour empêcher
sa propagation et notamment le
développement des formes les plus graves
qui ont amené malheureusement un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes soient à
décéder soit à souffrir encore
aujourd'hui de des séquelles et y
compris du côté de long qui n'est
toujours pas reconnue cependant sur la
question des personnels tant de santé
que des sapeurs pompiers
nous mesurons maintenant le temps
faisant la difficulté qui peut d'abord
faire preuve d'une incompréhension le
pass vaccinale n'existe plus il y a donc
aujourd'hui des sapeurs-pompiers qui
sont vaccinés qui sont en possession
d'un schéma vaccinal complet qui
pourtant sont porteurs du virus nous
avons des personnels soignants qui sont
dans la même situation et nous venons de
rappeler monsieur le rapporteur l'a
d'ailleurs précisé que compris à
l'entrée de l'hôpital à l'entrée de
l'hôpital il n'y aura plus de décès pas
de pardon il n'y aura plus de passes
vaccinale demande et donc je crois que
nous avons réellement à réfléchir et la
question n'est pas l'être dans une
vision jusqu'au boutiste mais nous avons
besoin en métropole comme dans les
outre-mers de ces femmes et de ces
hommes de personnel soignant deux
sapeurs pompiers professionnels ou
volontaires pour répondre aux urgences
de cet été alors moi je ne souhaite pas
son gouvernement qui décide je pensais
autres parlements justement de décider
comment les réintégrer avec des tests
avant la prise de service sur certains
postes de service plutôt que d'autres
mais en tout état de cause monsieur le
ministre monsieur rapporteur nous
pouvons soutenir cet article tel que
rédigé merci monsieur à la mine ou
merci mais la présidente je voulais
intervenir parce que je ne voterai pas
cet article daubisse je voterai
évidemment les amendements suppressions
qui seront présentées par mes collègues
je veux dire simplement plusieurs choses
en voyant cet article j'en ai discuté
avec le rapporteur hier encore je me
suis interrogé sur le personnel médical
et sur le personnel médical non vaccinés
j'ai repris les chiffres de juin
provence alpes côte d'azur en provence
alpes côte d'azur il y a deux chu la
peine marseille lch unissent des gros
hôpitaux tout autour et puis et c'est
sur l'ensemble des milliers de
personnels médical médecins et personnel
médical de ces sanitaires de ces
hôpitaux et sur l'ensemble des
personnels soignants des
maisons de retraite nous avons en tout
et pour tout sur la région paca
exactement selon ars
264 personnel suspendu sur les milliers
de personnes qui travaillent dans les
hôpitaux et dans les hospices donc ça
c'est vraiment des gens qui refusent la
vaccination et les ailes et réintroduire
sert introduire des gens qui refusent la
vaccination et c'est donc permettre de
faire un précédent avec des gens qui
lorsqu'ils seront pour être embauchée à
l'hôpital peuvent être vaccinés contre
l'hépatite doivent être vaccinés
comptait thanos refuseront ce genre de
vaccination et si on leur refuse
l'entrée dans l'hôpital parce qu'ils
refusent tétanos et l'hépatite et iront
vers un juge et le juge pourra s'appuyer
sur le précédent que vous créez
aujourd'hui donc vraiment comme l'a dit
madame guillotin dans son intervention
il y à un risque majeur de créer une je
sais pas si le terme exact mais une
jurisprudence en tout cas un précédent
extrêmement important et comment
allez-vous faire après pour les parents
qui refusent la vaccination pour leurs
enfants sur la rougeole pour les refuser
en crèche ou à l'école comment allez
vous faire pour les parents qui refusent
le papillomavirus la vaccination contre
le palais mavs papillomavirus nous
créons un précédent extrêmement
dangereux je voterai contre on intime de
glisse j'en ai évidemment les
amendements de suppression merci cher
collègue madame raymonde poncet mange
merci madame la présidente alors au
moins aussi en préalable je rappelle que
la crise qu vide a poussé le
gouvernement à lancer une vaste campagne
de vaccination
largement suivi qui a permis de sauver
de nombreuses vies bien la vaccination a
été rendue obligatoire pour les
soignants et les sapeurs pompiers mais
nous avons à juste titre ici refusé le
licenciement des personnes qui alors en
poste 1 c'est pas un long gauche alors
on poste refuser la vaccination créant
dès lors un ofni législatives dans le
droit du travail une suspension sans
rémunération pour un motif nouveau
interdisant le licenciement n'obligeant
pas la démission on estimait vous l'avez
dit l'an passé à 15 mille le nombre des
soignants concerné deux tiers aurait été
réintégrés bien mais que faire de ceux
qui restent ces soignants vont ils
rester suspendue advitam eternam sans
vision sur les conditions de leur
réintégration à part la vaccination bien
sûr il faut donc éclaircir les critères
qui justifie de maintenir cette
suspension en fait les mêmes qu'il du
maintien dans l'obligation puisque nous
savons que nous allons désormais vivre
avec l'aco vite les raisons qui nous ont
fait adopter l'article 1a nous
conduisent à poser légitimement cette
question qu'en foot de soignants quand
même des soignants vacciner mais
contaminés sont autorisés à exercer voir
sont rappelés je suppose qu'on à
examiner le calcul bénéfice risque qu'on
juge alors suffisantes les mesures
barrières il est temps de réinterroger
c'est légitime la suspension encore en
vigueur de centaines d'infirmiers est
toujours impératif est justifiée au
regard des risques nosocomiaux et sur
quels critères ont jugé nous devons
trancher à moins de vouloir punir à vis
des soignants qui ont refusé une sorte
de bannissement j'entends cela un petit
peu chez certains décidé alors dans ce
cas là il fallait les licencié il faut
être cohérent décès est dessinée sur est
seulement de suspendre sur des raisons
objectives la haute autorité de santé
donc doit d'abord préalablement définis
merci ça il faudrait la transparence sur
les critères de l'obligation qui veut
mais si chers collègues la suspension
dans l'air victoire gesma
bien si même la présidente alors je
voudrais à ce stade attiré l'attention
sur les personnels qui sont vaccinées
parce que ce sont les personnes qui met
aussi en danger parce qu'ils sont pour
la plupart en burn out sur les personnes
fatiguées
épuisé pour la plupart donc je pense
qu'il faut aussi humaniser notre
démarche ce sont des personnes qui sont
en souffrance et qui ne peuvent pas
prendre leurs congés leur récupération
voilà tout simplement ce que je voudrais
dire
merci mais marie noëlle lienemann
oui chers collègues j'entends certains
collègues s'émouvoir des démissions dans
l'hôpital public on aurait été terrassé
brutalement l'hôpital n'aurait pu le
personnel à cause des refus de
vaccination j'aurais aimé chers
collègues que vous soyez plus mobilisés
quand avec mon groupe et beaucoup
d'autres nous demandions à l'état de
recruter dans les hôpitaux de mieux
rémunérer les soignants et les
personnels et d'avoir un plan si je puis
dire marshall pour être rapide pour
sauver les hôpitaux là on vous entendez
pas c'était pas grave si on pouvait
s'arranger mais maintenant tu aurais
tous les mondes lhopiteau des hôpitaux
viendrait du fait qu'il n'y a pas de
soignants tel et 30 soignants pour
refuser la vaccination - gestion total
accord avec ce qu'a dit monsieur millon
au bout d'un moment au bout d'un moment
dans notre pays s'il n'y a pas un
équilibre entre le libre arbitre de
chacun la responsabilité qu'il prend
pour l'assumer et la loi générale qui
s'impose à tous eh bien nous savons dabo
coup de souci à nous faire
parce que c'est la crise de l'intérêt
général qui s'exprime
à partir du moment où nous avons décidé
pour des raisons de protection et quand
on est malade soi même on est quand même
plutôt rassurés de penser que les
personnels sont vaccinés même si
lucidement on sait que c'est pas à zéro
risque c'est le principe dit de
précaution
il faut prendre toutes les précautions
possibles même si elles ne sont pas
absolues donc moi je crois que si on
commence à mettre le doigt dans
l'engrenage
que chacun décide que c'est bien fondé
ou pas on peut contester la loi je
comprends que certains la conteste pas
ce qu'ils sont pas d'accord il dit ça
sert à rien moi même et moi je crois que
nous avons intérêt à défendre pied à
pied les principes que nous avons en
effet la fonction publique c'est des
responsabilités qu'on assume des
contraintes des libertés et un certain
nombre d'avantagés de statut pour moi je
remercie vous demande de ne pas accepter
la réintégration des soignants mais si
les cellules terme et oui merci madame
la présidente monsieur mise mes chers
collègues d'abord je voudrais relayer la
demande de chiffres précis agrégé
monsieur le ministre qui vous avez qui
vous a été faite est formulée très bien
par un parent s'il ya de noël je crois
qu'on a vraiment besoin d'avoir des
chiffres objectifs qui nous permet
d'avoir une idée de ce que représente
l'effectif réel fonction publique
hospitalière
salariés de droit privé professions
libérales
voulons pompiers professionnels et
volontaires pour qu'on sache vraiment
dans le pays à l'instant où on se parle
vous avez les éléments statistiques qui
vous permettent de répondre à cette
question du sionisme et de ne jamais
dire ah bah tiens on va prendre un
chiffre comme par hasard dans une dans
une ars dans le domaine hospitalier ça
donne 200 et quelques câpres et moi j'ai
les pompiers ah bah ça donne 200 et
quelques chez les pros en oubliant qu'il
ya 5000
volontaires qui sont qui ne sont plus en
capacité de remonter aujourd'hui dans un
dans un vs avez
deuxième chose je remercie le rapporteur
puisqu'avec son amendement il permet
qu'on est que ce débat ait lieu parce
que je sache je n'ai pas mémoire nous
ayons décidé ici pour ceux qui l'ont
voté pour ceux qui ont voté la
suspension des soignants non vaccinés
que nous les ayons suspendu à vitam
aeternam et antoine flahault professeur
de médecine à genève dit que le maintien
de la suspension des soignants non
vaccinés n'est plus fondée sur le plan
scientifique ayant en effet il n'ya en
effet pas de raisons d'exiger le vaccin
chez les soignants car il n'évite pas ni
ne réduit pas suffisamment les
contaminations des nouveaux variance du
sascoc 2 sur un plan éthique il n'y a
pas davantage de raison de ne pas
réintégrer les personnes non vaccinées
par ce qu'il penserait différemment des
vaccinés mais une condition de leur
embauche que d'avoir des raisonnement
scientifique validée par le gouvernement
ne pas réintégrer les non-vaccinés sans
un minimum de fondement scientifique
créerait un précédent
questionnable en termes de gestion des
fonctionnaires blâmer ses personnels de
santé je cite toujours pour leur
comportement passé irresponsable et
illégale oui c'est flahaut qui parlent
ne pas les réintégrer non quand on
flahaut professeur de médecine personne
qui a énormément intervenu pendant le
bel si chers collègues
voici
donc deux amendements que nous allons
étudier identique et faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune donc et ce sont
des amendements de suppression et le
premier 52 même guillotin merci madame
la présidente alors à nouveau je crois
que tout à tout a été dit pour expliquer
la suppression de cet amendement et qui
mirent qui remet en cause le principe de
réintégration d'aidé soignant non
vaccinés a déjà c'est une modification
du régime de gassion vaccinale qui a été
décidée à un moment où la crise
sanitaire était là on parle bien de
l'obligation vaccinale et la situation
sanitaire aujourd'hui on l'a dit tous
dans cet hémicycle n'est pas derrière
nous mais encore en situation d'épidémie
et cette obligation vaccinale des
soignants ma perdure et je crois que la
moindre des choses pour un soignant
c'est de la respecter je crois comme
certains l'ont dit à la fois en la
science bien évidemment la médecine mais
surtout en l'intérêt général et je ne
pense pas que chacun dans une société
dans un métier dans un établissement
puisse décider de son côté ci se vaccine
où il se vaccinent pas je alors on m'a
dit oui mais
en fait avant c'était pas comme ça ou
alors pourquoi séparer intérêts intégré
mais moi quand j'ai fait des études de
médecine plusieurs ici l'ont fait moi si
j'avais pas mon certificat de
vaccination contre l'hépatite b enfin je
pense que tout le monde était pareil et
bah nous ne faisions pas de stages terre
je ne rentrais pas en médecine on
demandé donc c'est rien n'a changé en
fait dans le système jeu on a un débat
aujourd'hui sur cette réintégration
alors qu' un débat sur le fait est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la vaccination des
soignants est encore nécessaire ça c'est
un débat qu'il faudra avoir si elle
n'est pas nécessaire eh ben on à en
annuler cette cette obligation vaccinale
est bien évidemment que les soignants
non vaccinés sont réintégrés mais si la
science la médecine par les autorités
sanitaires et monsieur le ministre va
peut-être nous nous informer des
contacts qu'il a eus mais si cette
vaccination
vu le contexte sanitaire est encore
obligatoire et mali soignant non
vaccinés ne peuvent pas être en contact
avec des patients notamment les plus
fragiles tant des service de réa où on
sait que neuf patients sur 10 sont des
patients non vaccinés donc j'en dirai
pas beaucoup plus tout a été dit je vous
remercie madame lienemann d'ailleurs
pour le petit coup de gueule tout à
l'heure lorsque juste deux choses c'est
pas en répétant des choses fausses sans
cesse qu'elle devienne vrai merci
l'amendement 60 madame cohen oui merci
madame la présidente mes chers collègues
avec cet article 2 bis le rapporteur
propose une issue à la situation des
personnels soignants suspendu en leur
permettant en fait d'être réintégrés dès
lors que la situation épidémique et pis
demio logique constatée par la haute
autorité de santé ne nécessiterait plus
l'obligation vaccinale pour ses
personnels je veux saluer cet effort de
réécriture de la part du rapporteur
philippe bas il s'agit effectivement
d'une légère avancée par rapport au
texte initial du gouvernement
mais il nous paraît difficile au niveau
de notre groupe majoritairement de
laisser les personnels de santé suspendu
à cette évolution qui semble s'inscrire
sur le long terme et moi je pense que le
débat là devient plus intéressant parce
que il est moins binaire je pense que en
tout cas je fais partie de celles et
ceux qui trouvant que la vaccination
c'est une arme efficace pour combattre
effectivement cette pandémie même si ça
a été dit c'est pas suffisant mais en
tout cas c'est une manière de protéger
les personnes et patienter et les
patients mais on sait également les
limites au niveau de la contamination
et puis là quand on parle des personnels
mes chers collègues on s'attaque quand
même au droit du travail et ça c'est une
première si je puis dire c'est à dire
que est ce que ces personnels qui sont
des des personnels de santé qui sont des
pompiers est ce que finalement ils vont
être intégrés ou ces îles sont suspendus
advitam eternam
ça c'est pas possible
et en même temps on nous dit oui mais
c'est important ils doivent prendre
leurs responsabilités
mais est-ce que vis-à-vis de toutes les
responsabilités sont prises quand on
demande au personnel soignant alors
qu'ils ont locaux vides d'aller
travailler parce qu'il manque du
personnel là on ne s'occupe pas des
problèmes de contamination là on ne
s'occupe pas de leur santé donc on veut
pas faire deux poids deux mesures et il
me semble important de dire aujourd'hui
que y compris continue de la situation
de nos hôpitaux des établissements
publics de santé il est important de
réintégrer ces personnels jour merci
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporte à
madame la présidente
les amendements dont il est question ici
porte sur la suppression d'une
disposition adoptée
par la commission des lois qui ne
prévoit pas la réintégration des
personnes non vaccinées
je tiens à le dire parce que la plupart
des interventions qui ont eu lieu
était soit contre la réintégration
soit pour la réintégration ce n'est pas
de ça qu'il s'agit vous pourrez
d'ailleurs renouveler votre prise de
position dans un instant parce qu'il y à
bien des amendements qui exige selon des
modalités différentes d'ailleurs la
réintégration je n'ai pas proposé la
rétractation la commission des lois la
commission des lois n'a pas adopté
d'amendements
procédant
à la réintégration
le sénat a voté l'obligation vaccinale
le sénat a également voté la suspension
d'activité des personnels soignants
principalement qui n'étaient pas
vaccinés dans le but de protéger les
malades des personnes âgées les
personnes handicapées en établissement
médico social je tiens à ce que les
choses soient claires
parce que c'est ainsi qu'elle se
présente
mais à la différence des vaccinations
qui sont nécessaires pour l'accès à la
fonction publique hospitalière
la vaccination contre le coc ville est
une vaccination temporaire les
personnels qui n'ont pas voulu se faire
vacciner n'ont pas été licenciés
leur lien avec le service public
hospitalier ou avec une clinique ou un
établissement médico social privé n'est
pas rompu
la suspension du contrat de travail est
par définition temporaire et non
définitive que tous nos collègues qui
pense qu'on pourrait ne jamais
réintégrer ces personnels lesage bien le
droit applicable avant la proposition
adoptée par la commission des lois
exclu qu'il reste suspendue pendant
toute la vie si on avait voulu les
écarter définitivement de leur métier
pour des raisons qui tiennent à une
sorte de morale qu'un personnel soignant
ne devrait pas refuser de se faire
vacciner parce qu'ils exposent des
patients à un risque bien que tous ses
collègues sache bien que cette exigence
morale tout à fait respectable qu'il
voudrait voir imposer n'est pas dans le
droit positif actuellement applicables
donc tous ont vocation à reprendre un
jour leur travail est ce que nous
proposons où nous devons proposer qu'il
le reprenne maintenant
je réponds non
est ce que nous devons prévoir les
conditions dans lesquelles le
reprendrons je réponds oui et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que la commission des lois
a fait parce qu'actuellement c'est un
pouvoir discrétionnaire du gouvernement
ne pouvons faire confiance au
gouvernement ou ne pas lui faire
confiance en tout cas sa liberté
d'action est totale et nous avons pensé
face à un sujet qui effectivement ne
concerne pas de nombreux agents
mais un peu plus de 2000 c'est à dire
très peu d'argent à l'échelle de
l'emploi de plus d'un million de
personnes au sein du service public
hospitalier et des cliniques privées eh
bien ces quelques centaines de personnes
elles ont droit à des égards l endroit à
ce qu'on s'occupe d'elle
on n'a pas voulu qu'elle contamine la
cause est entendue mais enfin elles ont
une vie une famille un revenu à acquérir
par leur travail il est bon d'organiser
leur retour et de ne pas laisser ce
retour à la discrétion du gouvernement
nous voulons que une décision médicale
s'impose au gouvernement et c'est la
seule chose que nous ayons décidé alors
nous avons dit je pense que c'est
pertinent que c'est la haute autorité de
santé qui prendra la décision de dire ça
y est enfin libre le coc vide c'est fini
l'obligation vide maximale n'a plus de
sens pour le coc vide et puisqu'elle n'a
plus de sens le lendemain monsieur le
ministre vous serez en tort si vous ne
prenez pas le décret l'autorisant la
réintégration et pour être sûr que cette
haute autorité de santé
se prononce
au moment opportun et que les choses ne
traînent pas dans la situation se sera
absolument améliorer
nous disons que la haute autorité peut
s'autosaisir que le gouvernement peut la
saisir que le nouveau conseil qui se
substituera au conseil scientifique peut
la saisir mais aussi que les commissions
des affaires sociales de nous deux
assemblées auxquelles je crois monsieur
alain millon qui s'est exprimé tout à
l'heure peut faire confiance comme nous
tous pourront saisir la haute autorité
de santé c'est tout rien de plus et rien
de moins et c'est déjà un pas en avant
pour dire à ses personnels moi je pense
qu'ils ont eu tort de ne pas se faire
vacciner mais il avait la liberté de ne
pas se faire vacciner car on ne vaccine
pas de force en france en revanche nous
avons voulu mettre à l'abri les malades
les personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées et donc ils n'ont pas pu
rester au contact de ceux ci pas plus
que les pompiers qui actionne les
secours d'urgence et par conséquent
nous sommes maintenant je crois dans une
situation je le dis très sobrement où il
y a un chemin vers la réintégration de
ces centaines d'agents qui n'ont pas
reçu une punition mais qui se sont vu
imposer de ne pas preuve faire prendre
de risques aux malades et aux personnes
vulnérables y un chemin nous le créons
mais nous ne créons pas de manière
fantaisiste en disant scrogneugneu je
décide aujourd'hui mois
sénateurs
de les réintégrer parce que ceci n'a pas
de sens je crois que la décision doit
être médicale elle le sera et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous demande de
rejeter la suppression de notre article
2 bis et puis tout à l'heure je voudrais
demanderait également de rejeter la
réintégration seul souci d'équilibré de
mesures dont on a une certaine pratique
au sénat
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
il est minuit passé
je vous propose de prolonger notre
séance afin d'achever l'examen de ce
texte
je ne vois pas d'observation il en est
ainsi décidé
l'avis du gouvernement chez ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
la commission des lois a retenu un
dispositif équilibré sur les conditions
d'une levée le moment venu de
l'obligation vaccinale
facilitant notamment la saisine de la
haute autorité de santé pour se
prononcer sur son bien-fondé
je les ai parlé tout à l'heure de
transparence je fais donc être
transparent sur les derniers chiffres en
ma possession concernant le secteur
sanitaire
2605 suspension de personnel soignant et
non soignant parmi ces suspensions 75
médecin trente deux sages-femmes 608
infirmière six ans une aide soignante et
50 de kiné
l'avis du gouvernement et donc
défavorable à la suppression de cet
article introduit par la commission des
doigts
merci alors avant de donner la parole
pour explication de vote je voulais
juste informé l'assemblée que j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de ce que tu as
public à part le groupe l'est
républicain fin de la parole à monsieur
théophile à
la ministre chers collègues je voulais
pas intervenir sur ce sujet puisque ce
sujet a fait nos gros dégâts de très
beaux dégâts chez nous et qui continue
je suis de la loi de l'eau
je sais que 94 à 95% des soignants sont
vaccinés chez nous us delta
mais je raisonne en ratio rationne de
taux de chômage il y à peu près 180
personnes à 200 personnes qui sont
devant le chu
et qui ont décidé de vie d'enfer
domicile depuis quelques mois
c'est toute la guadeloupe à peu près qui
passe le matin devant le chu pour soit
donné à manger
soit laissé quelques 10 euros pour que
ces personnes puissent eux en tout cas
s'occuper de leurs enfants
pendant la période électorale
et vous savez chez nous 200 personnes ça
touche rapidement toute la guadeloupe
ils ont décidé les guadeloupéens de
faire la peau de tous ceux qui ne
soutenaient pas eh bien les suspendus
faire la faire la politique c'est devenu
un sujet national tout ce qui est dit et
qui prônait l'art
la non réintégration des soignants ont
été battus et ça c'est un pan deuxième
chose je parlais du taux de chômage eh
bien ces personnes là ne travaille pas
et non pas le revenu et c'est ce qui
rythme la vie aujourd'hui en guadeloupe
ce que je demande pourtant je suis un
défenseur du vaccin j'en ai trois et
très rapidement
j'étais président de la fédération
hospitalière des antilles et de la
guyane
je connais comment ça se passe je suis
je suis rationnelle ce que je demande
c'est qui et c'est une proposition un
billet pour que ces personnes là qui ne
travaillent pas puissent trouver le
moyen d'avoir une activité dans le cadre
d'une activité d'intérêt il faut qu'ils
puissent toucher au moins un revenu
c'est le temps viendra ils vont toucher
leur salaire puisqu'il ne sont pas
licenciés
puissent trouver une activité aval à
monsieur daumier
merci
merci madame la présidente moi je
souscris au fait qu effectivement même
si sarthe cet article 2 bis était voté
aucun soignant ne sera réintégré à court
terme parce que tant que l'épidémie
continuera et des vagues sont à venir et
bien l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants sera maintenu et cet article 2
bis ne propose pas de réintégrer des
personnes alors que l'obligation
vaccinale est en vigueur donc
effectivement
il faut être cohérent si on veut que ces
soignants reprennent leur travail il
faut soit levé l'obligation vaccinale et
je n'ai pas entendu qu'il en soit
question soit sino abattre abattre une
valeur fondamentale de l'engagement dans
un métier de soignant qui est d'accepter
de se plier à des règles de protections
collectives de solidarité réciproque
au-delà de son propre choix individuels
et si cette porte est ouverte eh bien
les dégâts seront considérables
dans notre société
confronté à cette question
il eût été plus sage de s'en tenir au
dispositif actuel qui prévoit que par
décret après avis de la haute autorité
de santé l'obligation vaccinale puisse
être levé et donc logiquement les gens
être intégrés mais le rapporteur a
choisi d'étendre le champ du projet de
loi et on verra bien éventuellement ce
que le conseil constitutionnel en dira
pour traiter cette question
ça n'apporte rien de plus ce n'est qu'un
message politique qui est envoyé et qui
prend que place et patrick kanner l'a
dit dans le cadre des nouveaux
équilibres politiques de nos assemblées
et nous avons même assisté aujourd'hui
dans notre hémicycle un retrait par le
groupe qui soutient toujours le
gouvernement d'un amendement contre
l'avis du gouvernement mais pour faire
passer
le texte avec la majorité l ère du sénat
pourquoi pas mais il faut le dire
clairement ce n'est pas une posture
scientifique ou autre c'est un choix
politique
merci monsieur chat sont
donc je mets dans le sens où tout ce que
and heroes bernard jomier s'ils
voulaient la réintégration du personnel
ne peut pas être fait tout de suite
d'ailleurs elle sera faite par la part
la chef si l'évolution de la situation
épidémiologique ne justifie donc c'est
pas du tout pour pour l'instant mais en
fait je voterai l'amendement de madame
guillotin vernet guillotin pourquoi
parce que si vous voulez on retrouve on
retrouve à l'article 12 de la loi du 5
août 2021 le point câpres qui permet au
gouvernement par décret après avis de la
chaise de réintégrer tout ou partie des
soignants non vaccinés alors ce qui
après avoir voté l'article de uys pourra
être fait par la chaîne mais déjà ça
peut être faible dans le cadre de la loi
du 5 août 2021
alors donc comme je vous l'avais dit
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe l'est républicain
sur les amendements identiques
oui merci mais la présidente je ne serai
pas très longue mais concernant le
personnel soignant dans ce mot qui
englobe soignants et il ya des
personnels administratifs
on a tous rencontrés des personnels
administratifs des hôpitaux des centres
médico sociaux qui sont aussi touchés
par l'interdiction d'exercer or ils ne
sont pas en contact avec les malades moi
je on a reçu par exemple des des
pédopsychiatres qui qui travaillent avec
les établissements scolaires qui
prennent les enfants dans une salle de
20 mètres carrés et qui sont à distance
d'un enfant alors que cet enfant va être
avec 30 autres enfants dans une salle de
classe les enseignants n'ont pas
l'obligation de se faire vacciner et
pourtant ils sont avec beaucoup
d'enfants tout cas quand même des
professions dans ce set globalité du
personnel soignant qui pourrait être
remis au travail sans danger et tout le
monde n'est pas à achever de quelqu'un
qui est en réanimation il ya absolument
aucune logique et qu'aucun bon sens à
suspendre quelqu'un qui est du personnel
administratif travaillant dans un
établissement hospitalier hospitalier au
médico social je crois qu'il faut
réfléchir à ça aussi merci merci
vraiment monsieur le rapporteur très peu
de temps parce que si vous voulez passer
la nuit avec moi il n'y a pas de souci
mais en revanche
ce sera pas
à votre détriment il a fallu
il a fallu madame la présidente
allez-y il a fallu madame le président
attendre le jour de mon anniversaire
que vous ayez des paroles aussi suave à
vos oreilles
et je tiens à vous en remercier
publiquement
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais simplement dire à notre
excellente collègues que nous avons
pensé au cas qu'elle vient de signaler
puisqu'il est prévu dans notre texte
que les l'obligation vaccinale pourra
être levé par catégorie successives de
personnel effectivement la haute
autorité de santé pourra très bien dire
que telle ou telle catégorie de
personnel parce qu'elle est éloigné des
personnes vulnérables
on peut lever son obligation vaccinale
plutôt que pour d'autres
leurs collègues malgré l'heure tardive
et et ricanements alors je crois que
cette question est éminemment politique
au sens étymologique du mot à savoir
comment est ce que nous faisons société
ensemble et notre collègue théophile a
dit avec ses propres mots mais nous ne
sommes pas simplement sur une question à
savoir combien de personnels soignants
sont aujourd'hui interdits d'exercer
leur profession est suspendu nous ne
sommes pas aujourd'hui à savoir quel est
le ratio de personnes qui pourraient
être des sapeurs pompiers qui ne sont
pas nous sommes dans une question qui
est nous n'allons pas rouvrir le débat
ici je vous rassure monsieur ministre et
mes collègues
qui résultent de comment la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire et de la situation
vaccinale a été fait et discuter ici au
parlement comme dans le reste de la
société donc l'on pourrait se renvoyer
autant que de besoin qu'il s'agit d'un
monde finalement marginal de personnes
nous pourrions vous dire comme ça a été
fait qu'il y à un nombre
très important de profession qui
aujourd'hui sont en contact avec le
public sont des vecteurs de transmission
qui ont vécu cette septième vague à
l'heure où les masques sont tombés et
qui pour autant n'était pas soumis à une
obligation vaccinale est donc ce n'est
pas simplement qu'une question
anecdotique ou de décret à venir je
crois que c'est très sincèrement
aujourd'hui comment est-ce que certains
se sentent d'abord exclu à tort ou à
raison je ne reviens pas sur ce que j'ai
dit précédemment et comment est-ce que
collectivement nous allons réintégrer
l'ensemble de ces personnes pour
continuer de faire société ensemble et
de servir l'ensemble de la population
nous voterons bien évidemment notre un
moment merci donc nous allons procéder
donc au scrutin public qui a été
demandée par le groupe l'est républicain
sur les amendements identiques 50 de
rectifier 60 rectifié je vous rappelle
que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable à vis du gouvernement est
défavorable le scrutin public aura lieu
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 121
sur les amendements identiques numéro 52
rectifié quad terres et 60 rectifier et
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs groupe politique est notifiée
à la présidence nombre de votants 338
nombre de suffrages exprimés 334 pour
l'adoption 104 contre 230 le sénat n'a
pas adopté
alors nous passons à l'examen des
amendements suivant le 1 rectifié madame
noël
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
comme évoqué tout à l'heure mon
amendement a pour objet de réintégrer
immédiatement
les soignants et d'abroger sans tarder
cette obligation vaccinale petite
précision mes chers collègues lorsque je
remets en cause le fait que
le vaccin puisse protéger de la
transmission et de la portabilité du
virus je ne remets pas en cause son
efficacité sur sa protection contre les
formes graves voilà je me sens
véritablement attaqué à chaque fois et
je pense que cette mise au point elle
est essentielle
regardons nous nous avons tous repris
aujourd'hui une vie normale on a plus de
masquer les gestes barrières on les a un
petit peu mis de côté donc oui on est de
nouveau dans une petite vague voilà
d'épidémie de cas mais encore une fois
ce ne sont pas forcément des cas graves
est aujourd'hui le coc vide ils tuent
environ
j'ai regardé les derniers chiffres ça se
tient c'est entre 50 et 70 personnes par
jour sachez juste que le cancer tue
entre 350 et 400 personnes par jour on
peut donc considérer qu'on est quand
même rentré dans une phase endémique et
que les conditions me semble aujourd'hui
réunies si elles ne sont pas réunies
aujourd'hui quand le seront elles elles
ne le seront jamais parce que si on
attend qu'il n'y ait plus de pression
sur les hôpitaux vu l'état dans lequel
sont nos hôpitaux malheureusement on
n'en sortira jamais donc faut quand même
aussi se souvenir qu'il ya la quasi
totalité des pays dans le monde qui ont
levé cette obligation vaccinale des
soignants
est-ce qu'on va être le seul sur la
planète à le maintenir
bref dans mon département je tiens quand
même à apporter mon témoignage
bon nombre de ces soignants et de
pompiers sans perspective d'avenir ont
d'ores et déjà opté pour une
reconversion dans d'autres secteurs
d'activité ou alors dans certaines
régions frontalières comme la haute
savoie ils sont tout simplement partie
en suisse il faut que cette obligation
conclure elle n'est pas requise donc
vraiment je vous demande véritablement
soutenir cet amendement merci merci
l'avis de la commission sur la porter
monsieur le rapporteur
je suis défavorable où tout comme la
commission des lois à ces amendements
j'ai précisé à madame noël qui a comparé
le nombre de morts du cancer au nombre
de morts dus qu'aux vide actuellement
qui a du point de vue de la vaccination
des personnels une différence c'est que
qu'on ne peut pas contaminer un malade
du cancer ou plutôt une personne dans
faisons qu'elle soit affectée par le
cancer
si on n'est pas vacciné et tandis qu'on
peut éviter de contaminer à malades
de l'hôpital par le cos vite si on n'est
pas vaccinée c'est cette comparaison n'a
pas tellement de sens voilà ce que
j'essaye d'expliquer à cette heure
tardive de notre débat en tout cas
l'avis est défavorable ainsi l'avis du
gouvernement monsieur ministre mais ma
vie madame la présidente merci alors
pour expliquer addition de voix de
monsieur juillet
oui madame la présidente merci parce que
malgré l'heure tardive on peut pas
laisser lire dans cet hémicycle des
choses qui sont totalement fausses et
oui parce que le vaccin n'annule pas la
transmission mais la réduit et ça n'est
pas rien la réduction de la transmission
ça n'est pas inintéressant on va le
répéter à chaque fois que vous avancerez
dvd fait qu'ils sont inexacts mais nous
ne sommes effectivement pas dans des
dispositifs efficaces à 100 % et nous
personne n'a prétendu que les vaccins
éviter 100% des formes graves et 100%
des transmissions c'est un outil un
parfait mais c'est le meilleur qu'on est
jusqu'à aujourd'hui puis deuxièmement il
a tué ce virus depuis le début de
l'année 25 mille personnes sur les six
premiers mois ça fait pas soixante dix
par jour je vous invite à sortir votre
calculette ça fait deux fois plus
il tue il a tué du 1er janvier au 30
juin on verra plus tard pour les
chiffres du 17 juillet si ça vous amuse
mais 25000 personnes ça veut dire une
moyenne de cinquante mille par an et
l'on a tué sans ce sens il a tendu et
150000 français depuis le début de la
pire de l'épidémie ça en fait un des
problèmes de santé publique majeur de
notre pays au même niveau que le tabac
l'alcool ou la pollution de l'air alors
minimisé sans cesse les chiffres
minimisé l'intérêt des outils de lutte
je me demande quel est le fond de tout
ça qu'est-ce que vous poursuivez comme
but de nier de nier la nécessité qu'une
société adopte des mécanismes collectifs
pour se protéger contre une menace de
sanitaires de premier ordre et ben moi
ça me laisse pantois parce que eh oui
parce que vous faites simplement la
défenseure du mois jeu et je ne veux
aucune contrainte et je balaye et je
minimise sans cesse la réalité et vous
ne pouvez pas le nier c'est bien
cinquante mille décès annuels sur la
pente sur laquelle on est en ce moment
merci madame goy chavent
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre sur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
on est quand même dans une sacrée
hypocrisie
faute de soignants faute de pompiers ont
somme ces gens d'aller au travail
malades du covan enfin il faut quand
même ici que quelqu'un le dise on laisse
hommes d'aller travailler parce qu'on a
plus de personnel oui des infirmiers et
des infirmières en réanimation c'est pas
la peine de dodeliner des infirmiers et
des infirmières en réanimation malades
ducobu devons au chevet de leurs
patients il faut quand même que
quelqu'un le dise ici
donc moi je voudrais savoir pourquoi se
priver de ses personnels
franchement il vaut mieux qu'ils aillent
travailler sans être malade avec
éventuellement un test pcr avant plutôt
que des personnes vaccinées parce qu'ils
sont vaccinés haye quand même travaillé
malades fiévreuse enfin quand même
il faut ouvrir les yeux moi je sais pas
je suis effaré de cette discussion
jeu j'attends monsieur le ministre votre
réponse solennel dites moi pourquoi vous
acceptez que des personnels soignants et
des sapeurs pompiers soient obligés
d'aller travailler alors qu'ils sont
souffrants du coc vite
merci monsieur joyandet
oui merci vers la présidente c'est pour
soutenir monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président l'amendement de cydia noël
également parce que ya une chose que
l'on sait aujourd'hui on essaie de
prendre des décisions par rapport à la
situation d'aujourd'hui pas par rapport
à la situation d'hier on sait
qu'aujourd'hui
le vaccin ne protège pas en tout cas pas
beaucoup delà de la contamination
première chose deuxième chose on sait
qu'il ya pas de hasard dans les grands
nombres ya pas de hasard dans les grand
nombre et à partir du moment où on sait
très bien qu'à on joue aujourd'hui
énormément de contamination ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'il ya aujourd'hui
énormément de soignants de pompiers de
d'autres personnes qui travaillent en
ayant en ayant le coc vide qui se sont
d'ailleurs pas tester donc
il ya effectivement une situation
d'aujourd'hui qu'il faudrait prendre en
compte parce que entre quelqu'un qui est
vacciné malades du cobp ide qui
travaillent est quelqu'un qui ne peut
pas travailler parce qu'il n'a pas été
vaccinés et quand on sait que cette
vaccination ne protège pas c'est
peut-être le moment justement de
d'accélérer un peu sur le retour des
agents dans leur service au moment où on
a le plus besoin et puis moi je pense
pas franchement que ce soit une question
de chiffres pas une question de nombre
c'est une question de principe dans la
société on peut peut-être se dire qu'à
un moment donné on les a exclus parce
que on vient on avait peut-être pas tous
les éléments ou peut-être fallait-il le
faire à ce moment-là mais si les
éléments ont changé est-ce qu'on laisse
et citoyennes et les citoyens comme ça
sur le bord de la route dont un certain
nombre non plus de salaire depuis des
mois et des mois alors qu effectivement
je confirme ce qui vient d'être dit
d'autres citoyennes et citoyens qui sont
malades qui ont le coc vide ils vont
travailler avec un masque donc c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il faut lire examiner la
situation et c'est peut-être aujourd'hui
qu'il faut avancer sans pour autant
attendre que le gouvernement prenne une
décision sous une autorité quelconque
dont on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
laquelle ce sera un
merci madame
merci madame la présidente moi je
voulais juste préciser que le taux de
survie au qu'ovide c'est
99,8 % au pire donc on parle on parle
pas des veaux là on parle pas du on
parle du pire 99 8 % de personnes
survivent au co vide je voulais préciser
aussi que si on pense qu'au bout d'une
troisième dose de vaccin
elle est valable quatre mois puisque au
bout de quatre mois il faut recommencer
bien les plus personnelles vacciner
aujourd'hui dans quatre mois ne l'est
plus il n'est plus considéré comme avoir
un schéma vaccinal complet donc est-ce
qu'on remet ce personnel en cause on
sait que dans les hôpitaux aujourd'hui
parce que il y a besoin de personnel les
chefs d'établissement n'oblige plus à la
troisième ou à la quatrième dose sinon
sinon plus personne donc c'est
malhonnête c'est malhonnête
et peut-on devons nous rester dans une
décision qui est aujourd'hui injustes et
malhonnêtes
merci monsieur opère
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues devant la
mort il faut être humble devant la
maladie faut être humble arrêtons nous
battre avec des chiffres nous sommes
face à une injustice
à une inégalité
face à des gens qui n'ont plus de
travail qui n'ont pas la possibilité
puisqu'ils sont toujours intégré d'aller
chercher un autre travail
un peu d'humanité
hospital l'hôpital dire ce vient
d'hospitalité un peu de spiritualité
merci alain jeu mieux mais messi
fialaire s'avoue
j'entends parler d'humilité je crois
qu'il en faut un petit peu d'humilité
effectivement j'entends parler aussi de
principe je crois qu'il en faut des
principes on a vraiment un problème dans
notre société de respect de l'autorité
il ya un manque d'autorité l'ours papa
de l'autoritarisme les choses mais d'une
autorité de compétence alors on peut
dire que l'académie de médecine ce
qu'elle dit n'importe quoi les facultés
de médecine c'est n'importe quoi nos
hautes autorités de la santé
c'est n'importe quoi on peut citer un
professeur moi je pourrais citer le
professeur out aussi bien qu'ils étaient
une sommité faut arrêter je pense que
dans une société dans notre république
qui prône aussi la solidarité la
fraternité faut avoir en respect de
certaines règles
si on respecte pas un minimum de règles
si on ne les fait pas respecter si on
n'est pas exemplaire quelle image on
donne à l'ensemble de notre société à
nos enfants aux simples citoyens qui
font confiance lorsqu'ils vont dans des
services de soins pour recevoir
justement des soins qui sont peut-être
pas
exactement
ce que l'on souhaiterait mais qui qui
sont l'objet de consensus le fruit de
consensus scientifique et qui ont été
approuvés alors effectivement un peu
d'humilité s'il vous plaît et puis un
respect de certains principes qui est
celui du respect de l'autorité
merci jeu mais je mets au voile
amendement numéro 1 rectifié qui a reçu
un avis défavorable de la commission et
du gouvernement qui et pour
[Musique]
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 35 que monsieur
durel
c'est madame la présidente monsieur
michel collègues j been entendu les
explications de notre reporter
les personnels
aujourd'hui suspendu n'ont pas vocation
à le rester à l'internât mme ils ont
bien vocation à réintégrer leur travail
c'est la raison pour laquelle je n'ai
pas à voter la suppression de cet
article de l'iss en revanche manger un
autre problème si le contrat le travail
n'est pas suspendu j'ai un problème moi
d'affectation et j'ai un problème de
respect et de discipline d'autorité
évoqué il y à un moment de discipline
quelque part oui à la réintégration mais
non à l'affectation je vais des malades
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
propose un moyen terme de dire si cette
vocation est bien là ils peuvent
réintégrer leur travail et suites
d'accords pour la réintégration mais non
pas à leur affectation au chevet du
malade ou des personnes fragiles ou
vulnérables je vois mal comment un
directeur d'établissement
ne pourrait pas réinfectés ans je viens
la personne a subi une formation a subi
une
une obligation à respecter une
obligation vaccinale pour entrer dans le
métier il me semble et je parle sous
votre contrôle qui lie à 72,8 y est
éligible à l'obligation vaccinale il y à
une seule dose est une vocation plus que
professionnelle helvétique elle est
morale c'est de dire que vous devez
prendre soin de vos patients et donc moi
je propose que au lieu de laisser à la
seule discrétion du gouvernement on peut
faire confiance ou de laisser à une
haute autorité de santé ou à je ne sais
quelle autre machin
quels que soient leur expertise concept
au législateur de dire à cette autorité
réglementaire que
oui d'ores et déjà nous respectons cette
autorité là nous respectons cette morale
là et que nous excluons une affectation
au chevet du malade elle est le centre
l'amendement qui vous est présentée
merci l'avis de la commission sur la
porter il est défavorable modem le
président si l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur ministre mais ma vie madame le
président merci je vais donc aux voix
l'amendement numéro 35 qui a reçu non
non mais quand je commence le vote avant
il fallait réagir avant donc je vais
vous laisser la parole mais je vous le
dis je vous le dis quand je démarre
l'opération de vote c'est fini je sais
même donc merci pour cet
eg8 comprendre l'explication en quoi le
pouvoir dont directeur serre diminuent
et celui serait impossible puisque le
contrat de travail n'est pas rompu de
réaffecter angoy en quoi elle et ça
permettra aux gens de retrouver leur
travail en quoi c'est impossible et moi
pour une explication plus clair que je
j'ai compris il faut aller vite mais moi
je ne me pose pas la réintégration je
m'oppose à une affectation chevet du
malade
alors je me vois donc
l'amendement 35 a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
ces contrôles qui s'abstient n'ont pas
adopté la maman 16 monsieur le carré
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors cet
amendement vous pourrez considéré comme
un amendement de repli après le rejet
des différents amendements notamment
d'amendements de siviez noël c'est un
amendement qui ne se pose qui ne se
situe place pas sur le débat de
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants qui
ne remet pas en cause la rédaction
proposée par notre rapporteur et la
commission mais qui
parce que la situation actuelle
l'exigent parce que notre département la
haute-savoie et dans une situation des
sanitaires ou
l'aspirateur de ressources humaines vers
la suisse est déjà extrêmement puissant
que cette interdiction faite aux
soignants déjà c'est leur métier en
france les conduits directement vers des
employeurs suisses
parce que cette règle là n'existe pas
n'existe plus en suisse
et que cette réalité elle est transposa
dans tout un tas de deux départements à
besançon dans 10 grandes agglomérations
dans le monde rural moi je pense que le
temps est venu de la réintégration
immédiate des soignants donc je touche
pas à l'obligation vaccinale on touche
pas la rédaction du rapporteur philippe
bas mais de manière mécanique et
juridique cet amendement permet dès la
promulgation de la loi que les soignants
que non vaccinés ou qui ne sont pas à
jour de leurs obligations vaccinales
soient réintégrés
ça permet de dépassionner le débat
d'être
plus juridique mais je pense que
maintenant le temps est venu le débat
ait été utile je crois qu'il était utile
et merci monsieur le rapporteur de
l'avoir permis j'espère monsieur le
ministre si vous n'aurez intégré pas les
soignants d'en vacciner que vous auriez
que vous arriverez dans les mois qui
viennent a trouvé un argumentaire avec
une initiative pour le faire
merci alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur malgré
l'ingéniosité de cet amendement est
peut-être à cause de cette ingéniosité
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement sioniste
même avis dans le présent
merci
alors j'ai dit non c'est pas super vite
donc je me loupe fois que je faisais moi
tu commences à être un peu fatigué donc
je mets au voilà mon numéro 16 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable des commissions
du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté
alors j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public à part le groupe l'est
républicain sur l'article 2 bis donc il
va être procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions fixées par l'article 156
du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
t'as du scrutin numéro 122 sur la tique
numéro 2 bis compte tenu de l'ensemble
des délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au politique est notifiée à la
présidence nombre de votants 339 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 319 pour
l'adoption 229 contre 90 le sénat a
adopté
[Musique]